welcome to simple learn welcome to
return of value and you think the real
value of itl in enterprise my name is
martin stuffy and i'm your moderator and
also i'll be mostly in the background
helping some ages so that everything
goes smoothly
and after that i should say that we have
our trainer who will be conducting this
webinar as a return of value and i think
the real value of
itl in enterprises and his name is
summit ja and in order to improve our
services every feedback is essential and
we request you all to please take up
okay good thank you nabi to take up
the survey and provide feedback and the
end of this webinar through the through
the polling activity now let me come to
our trainer and i'm proud to introduce
amit as a guru who will conduct this
webinar as i said as a return of value
and everything the real value of itl in
the enterprises yes hello faizan
and samit chai's associate director
business development cis cognizant
technology solutions is an author and a
thought leader and an expert in iit
strategy and transformation has delivery
over 50 service management consulting
assignments for various banking finance
telco and the media
customers across the globe and
now just to come to the last part at the
end of this session we will have a 50
minutes question and answer time in
these 15 minutes
q and d time we will cover as many
questions as we can
then ever and already covered during
this session and if you are here
something uh hey some brilliant
interesting insightful and you want to
share in your social channel whatever
your social channel
are
facebook or linkedin tweet you can use
the hashtag assal webinars that way that
way people can find it and you will make
damage way
they were here you didn't come guys to
listen to me and i'm proud now to do the
handover to summit who will
be your host as i said and the name of
this webinar is return of value and
hurting the real value of
itl and enterprises go ahead and sit
back relax have a cup of coffee and
thank you for
your attending and
happy happy simply learning good morning
summit are you there are you with us are
you able to hear me
your model
okay now uh you should go ahead please
and uh just few sentences before you
started we know that it has a
big responsibilities and it enables the
business to meet goals and adapting
quickly to changing needs or minimizing
cost and complexity and we know that the
business challenges is increasing
business performance on improving roi or
rov and i'm really glad to know and hear
today's webinar
by you as a guru and welcome to today's
webinar and please
go ahead summit okay i will be in the
background
thank you
so hello everyone
this session uh is based on one of the
key concepts that we basically myself
and my co-author
rakesh had introduced in a book making
science work adopting service
integration and management for your
business thus you would often find quite
a bit of references to this book during
this session
the way
i have
sectioned this entire
session is based on the agenda we can
cover the current perception of the
industry has and going into how i t
projects is valid currently then we'll
get to the concept of return on value
and then
the last part would cover on how you can
adopt roe in your organization
so the perception
the challenge for cios have been
never this extreme
as you see the pressure from business
has constantly been building uh and
especially with the data age
this challenging situation has further
perplexed the cios
they need to have the right strategy for
social mobile analytics and cloud
technologies
in order to actually support the digital
transformation the businesses are going
through
doing one of the quick takes from cios
uh cio.com tried to get their thoughts
on how
do you communicate the value of i.t to
the business this was the question they
asked to the couple of cios and some of
the key observations uh from
the response is what has been captured
in the slide
so
cios feel that the role of i.t has
evolved from transactional department to
a strategic one
now i mind you these are basically the
quotes from uh
the cios who are rated as the successful
ones in the industry today so
communicating the value of its systems
is critical so they really realize that
is extremely important that the value of
it is effectively communicated to the
business and
that too in terms of all the systems
processes and solutions which it
used to provide services to the
business they need to provide extended
value to the customers beyond technology
especially if you see from the business
perspective they really do not really
understand what
technology means but then it is
what the customers are looking forward
for that
business
the iit should be talking beyond
technology because for
ideas not simply the business it is the
end customers as well who has to be
really satisfied
with the business services and all of
this is what really
is making the cio's life difficult today
because all of this has to be
effectively articulated to the
business
now one of the key another thing which
cios are looking forward for is
that
idea has to be established as a trusted
business partner for the business
so
these are some of the key points which
has been observed from
the cio.com
question map now
another research is here again i'm
referring to mit sloan
research
here if you see that traditionally a
business has viewed it as a cost center
now though id generates value for the
business but this
aspect of id has never really been
visible to the business
this has again followed been one of the
key challenges for every cio
during the survey conducted by mit sloan
one of the fortune 500
companies cio stated the business just
doesn't understand that information
technology organization supports the
business processes that they drive
the business defines the business
processes id enables the processes
leveraging information technology
again on a very similar note during one
of my consulting engagements one of the
cios told me that his problem was that
business does not see any value in their
id organization
they opined that
business ran on their business processes
and it just played a supporting role
they felt that it was not critical for
running these business processes they
were not able to relate the i.t services
to their business services and processes
thus never realizing that it is the key
enabler for their business
in the same organization when i
contacted with the
when i interacted with the ceo he stated
that their i.t is a capital consumer and
not a value creator so this is a
perception which i found in quite a few
organizations which business has towards
their writing
so following the observations have been
taken from mit sloan
now as we go through these observation
let us try to relate how commonly you
have experienced these statements and
also how we can use it to identify the
ways in which we can communicate the
value our it team brings to business now
one of the key point highlighted was
that many organizations are experiencing
a crisis in confidence in their
information system functions
especially for this is
on aspect of the cios who lead them
so
another area where
really
iot has not been able to
build their confidence
in business
now ceos often don't know how to really
evaluate
its functions performance and thus that
of the cio
even one ceo mentioned that why they
find it difficult to really evaluate the
performance of information systems and
the ciu's contribution
now
one of
the ceos who was a born skeptic
mentioned that he doesn't trust stories
of i.t based competitive advantage and
he thinks it doesn't apply to his
industry now why is this happening
because
all these ceos have never really
been able to understand or visualize the
value which iit has
provided the business with now the
culprit is not the cio's culprit is the
idea because we
have not really been able to showcase
what we actually do for our business
now in
another
statement which was which came out from
this research a cio believes that i.t
budget should not be subject to the same
disciplines as the rest of the business
business now here again it's a cio's
perception that you should not be
treated at par with
the business but
it's good to have that perception but
then you need to communicate the value
build the trust
and thus claim for those allocations in
the
entirely budgetary decisions of the
organization
now there's only a couple of ceos who
belong to
the different team where they really saw
it
as the enabler and value creator for
them now these ceos have it has been
observed that typically when they move
they have been taking along the cio with
them so the cia this particular set of
ceos believe that it can enable new and
smarter ways of doing business and that
the cios and the is function in general
should therefore be actively brought
into the business team
now this is the situation
where
id has really been able to communicate
the work
the value they bring to the business and
this is where exactly every uh it
organization want them to see and not
definitely in the first
five examples
statements we have seen here now
we will go to your survey i'll request
you to start the server
uh please
can start the survey please
yes amit
so what we need to do here is we want to
know that what metrics uh business used
to measure value and the purpose of the
survey is to really go that how many of
us really
understand these metrics completely so
the answers are accordingly
whether you if you know that the
variable like what metrics business used
to measure value which your team
provides to them then your answer should
be i know
that completely
if you have a decent idea of that then
you should be going for i have a good
idea uh if you are not very sure then
the third option and if you're
completely unaware in the fourth option
okay guys i would like you to
provide us response on the chat windows
hello guys okay please help us and
provide answers on your chatting windows
bella faizan jivan kumar
manjunath
milint mikhil
nishanth please go ahead
and provide us response to chatting
windows
priyanka ravi samir samir
shivanand
stress vijay
okay thank you guys
okay please all of you if you're able to
provide us response
and share your opinion referring to this
array number one
okay
okay thank you summit i think that we
have response in the chatting windows
from them and probably you should go and
continue with webinar
cemetery there
yeah
okay great i think that we have
responses from our guys here and you
should go ahead
now the next service on
are your metrics
really aligned to the business values
metrics
okay i hope that our guys we have that
the same thing just provide us and share
your opinion referring to survey number
two as we have these
options are you metrics aligned to
businesses value metrics
they have four options please share and
provide your responses referring to that
thank you guys
okay submit i think that we have
responses from them or most of them
share with us their opinion you should
go please
so now if i um see the survey frequently
most of us the responses which i have
got the most of us are not really
sure that what
metrics does business really consider
to value what it has
provided
to them
now this is a common trend it's not that
most of us here doesn't realize this but
this is the problem uh with each of us
in ikey space that we really
talk in a technical
jargon we use those technical charges to
communicate to the business and
unfortunately these are some things
which business does not really
understand
so
we will cover this more in detail in the
corresponding slides
so now some of the key reasons why uh
business does not really see the value
of i.t
so let us understand these reasons now
the key reason is that business
executives are not able to align the id
cost to their business services so
when
for every business unit a certain cost
is deducted from
them towards it services which
they consume
now
the common perception with each of these
business unit heads is that
they're just paying id but not sure
for what uh just sort of
systems and the things which it's
providing to them they are not able to
really relate it
to their business services so unless and
until the mapping happens with the
business services to
the i.t services which these bus consume
it's very difficult for them to align
the business outcomes to the it cost
which they are paying
second key reason is the inability of id
organization to communicate value in the
business term so just like i mentioned
earlier
if we say that a certain
server has been improved its reliability
has been improved rough time has been
improved
in many situations it does not make any
sense to the business
so
though
in the best case scenario we are able to
communicate some value which it has
created for the business but not in the
language which business really
understands
the third critical
point here is that buzz business is
unable to apprehend the value that i
generate now since they do not
relate to these services they are not
really able to apprehend and appreciate
the value which it provides to them
i.t communications constitute of debt
charges we told that idea initiatives
are not linked to business outcomes so
even a lot of initiatives that we take
within rit organization whether that is
a simple
service improvement plan or a major
change that we are bringing through
improving our processes improving our
systems
but unfortunately
these does not really relate to uh the
business
for them they are not able to really
relate the outcomes which each of these
initiative
provides
to the business services or
the services which they actually
consume
now
last critical point here is that value
of system processes or solutions are not
aptly communicated to the business
now
although in some cases we are able to
communicate
what value ideas are brought forth
but
those with respect to systems processes
solutions
that linkage again never happens so
value communication
is the key problem because of which
business does not really see
the value that iit brings forth to them
so let us see how it projects its
value
can we go through this example and
provide
the value which you perceive
it has created for the business the case
is that an it organization has
instituted proactive problem management
they did
the trend analysis based on which the
problem management
problem manager identified a certain
trend in the occurrence of a
set of incidents
the root cause analysis of this
productivity problem ticket resulted
in
identification of an issue which was
related to a server that was hosting a
critical business application
now as part of
the corrective preventive action they
were able to
improve
the uptime of the services by additional
certain percentage so
what value has this initiative created
for the business i would be
looking forward for your
answers
friends here
just a
few
30 seconds for this and let's see
what we all have to say regarding the
value that id has created for business
okay i hope that we should come with the
response and uh share your opinion with
our trainer and i will go and try to
read the responses from you guys
just go ahead and
type in chatting windows
what value has this initiative created
for the business
okay we have a are you able to see
responses submitter i'm going to read
the responses from some attendees
please confirm me summit
yeah as you see a response from given
value more availability
more opportunity for business to be
productive
thereby
given says increasing investment as well
any other
sorry not investment
okay
fine given thanks
amelia mentioned negligible value since
additional uptime is only 0.1 percent
manju says
every percentage of business service
increases so
okay
kumar says that
up need the past and new uptime absolute
percentage figures i t in this instance
would have created value
for the business only if the metrics
agreed was met
even men says i meant producing more
products
in case of manufacturing
and
bilal says that
overall there's an increase in the
dependability of business organizations
business service
to the customers
fine thanks everyone
we will be visiting this example
after certain um covering certain
concepts
again
another comment from
dwarf
convert the percentage into time which
it in turn helps us to calculate the
downtime
uh suraj says howard is not clear
it is increased from 99.99 to 0.1
percent
the chances additional uptime means less
incidence and less
service description for this critical
business application
fine thank you folks
so before i proceed further
i would
like to
really cover some more points
we have been talking about uh iit
constantly and how does it really relate
to our context
so
my question is why service management
itsm or ipl
and how can that drive the value of iit
so itself you see that is completely
cross-functional in nature it is the
only function that sees the services in
a complete sense
ik sms means our roles are most capable
in organization to understand and
communicate the criticality of business
processes and services
internally as well as
externally that means to the business
so they can communicate the criticality
and importance of id services to
our customers that means the business
in an ideal world i would like to see
service management function as the
intermediary layer between business
nightly organization
and in one of
the research it was said that
service management professionals are the
best suited to drive
service level automations
across
the domains
so success of iti initiatives thus
directly dependent on the proposition
and well directly proportional to the
contribution of every i.t team
that has been made to the initiative
thus value of these initiatives is
effectively communicated to business
would mean that it's values has been
communicated successfully
thus
though henceforth i may be focusing on
itil it's relevant extends to the entire
it organization
the outcome of any ideal initiative will
either be a gain or loss
so gain are the typical outcome
outcomes that have positive impact on
the organization now these may be
improvement in adherence up time
and so on
whereas um
the impacts which are negative um the
outcomes that has resulted in negative
impact
are the loss so example could be
degradation
in quality of the service
increase in the downtime and so on
so
the outcome is measured in the base unit
of the parameter improved or is
completely subjective at times like if
you see the point which
jimin
mentioned that
it would lead to an increased
manufacturing output
so how does that relate to that
particular output it could be subjective
so we will
get into more of these details when we
get into the concept of rov
now
typically
when we try to communicate these gains
or loss it's done in terms of percentage
of financial value or some other base
parameters
but most of
these outcomes are very difficult to be
quantified
so let us try to understand the type of
returns
which are there so the returns could be
tangible or it could be intangible so
tangible return is what i say is
that can be directly quantified in
financial terms so
i can directly say that yes this is the
financial
gain that has happened out of it and
those that cannot be directly converted
into or directly quantified in financial
terms is what is what i call as
intangible rectum it would be mostly
subjective and it may result in
any of the outcomes that may result in
intangible uh
or
indirect
gains or a period of time so intangible
outcome right now and india will gain
right now may eventually lead to
tangible gains but it would be over a
period of time
now intangible gains are also
significantly driven by perception so
this is where
when articulating the intangible values
it becomes really critical that how do
you really address that perception
so for id if you see most of the
benefits are intangible and this is why
it is very difficult to represent the
value it brings forth to the business
now
we found that the concept of uh tangible
intangible itself was slightly confusing
because
some of the gains like
uptime can be related to the benefits
and that may eventually be quantified in
financial terms so how do i say this
tangible or intangible so for me the
very confusion of trying to identify the
outcome of an initiative is when we get
lost into identifying what is tangible
and what is intangible and this is the
major reason
where i t
value articulation becomes
a
challenging ask for
the team members so we wanted to keep
the understanding of these returns very
simple and thus the specific definitions
are what we have used to introduce them
this is extremely critical for us to
relate the value we have really gained
from our initiative
so
how do we uh really convert intangible
into tangible so let us
understand
uh this so when we
try to identify uh the outcomes of any
initiative
the resultant gains would be direct or
indirect so for each gain we need to
associate the opportunity cost of not
doing or maybe the gain which has
happened directly because of this
so the associated result uh
so whatever reserved financial
valuations that we have got we need to
associate
that with the outcome so we attribute
the impact of the initiative to this
particular game
and then eventually we calculate the
resultant financial benefit
which is
quite
easy for our
uptime type of
initiative of time improvement type of
initiative
but not all intangible benefits can be
easily be converted into tangible values
games at operational levels can be
easily related to financial gains while
others could be more subjective and
complex to convert and especially when
the gain has has an indirect impact on a
different perspective or to whether
those value articulation there becomes
difficult
so let me again go back to our example
and say that if the opportunity
lost due to unavailability of the
services
10 000 usd per minute then what value
has this initiative created for the
business so
now
has
so basically this example now going back
to it the purpose is to see that
whether this information has a
perspective of the value that has been
generated has that changed for you
so can you just
do a quick calculation here
ah we will just see this calculation
so when we say opportunity cost is 10
000 usd per minute uptime gain
is 0.1 per year so if you try to relate
this
0.1 percent uptime gain would
translate into certain
minutes
and
when you multiply that with the
opportunity cost what you get is
the
value which you have created for the
business in terms of
enabling
that opportunity to go through so you
have prevented the opportunity loss and
thus you have
what you have done is you have gained
that opportunity you own that
opportunity for the business so here you
have been able to
bring value of 5.256 million usd
annually for the business
now
my question would be that is this the
only value that initiative has brought
to the business
so who are the direct or indirect
beneficiaries of the outcome
from our initiative so for any of the
initiatives if we see
the value
is what
is
eventually
been received by
your
it could lead to some strategy change
affecting your strategic layer it should
lead to improvement of your services
which may be ideal business services
just
be at it or business late it would have
a large impact on certain aspects of the
company the business itself the quality
of the business services or the i.t
services the excellence your customer
satisfaction
your individual team so all of these
perspectives uh or all of these
stakeholders basically are the direct or
indirect
beneficiaries of your outcome because it
is very important for us that each of
these
stakeholders understands the value that
we have brought to them
so it is
it is critical that we
listen to what our customers
that is a business wants to hear
not what we want to tell them right
typically when we try to communicate to
them we try to communicate what we want
to tell them not what they really want
to hear and this is where that
communication
gap arises they are not really able to
apprehend what we are telling them
so now i will introduce
you to the concept of return of value
we have used this concept to demonstrate
the benefits of siam initiatives to the
business network making sam work and
this is where we uh introduce this
concept i've also used this to help one
of my customers the earlier cio example
that i have given
to transform the perception of the
business and appreciate the value that
iit created for them so they were able
to effectively
use this concept to effectively
communicate to the business and
the perception of the business
completely changed
from basically a
consumer
of just a
cost or drain for the cost for business
to the real value generator
so i would like to recall a quote from
one of the cios and
if you see
rebecca jacoby who was the
cio of cisco way back in 2012
she mentioned that improving the value
of services is
all about how effectively you are able
to understand what business wants to
accomplish and then express that
outcomes in the business terms
which everyone in the business can
understand it is not really about the
technology but of the service but the
value that the service provides to the
business and this is precisely what
our concepts of rov uh try to address
so let me unwind and answer the question
that you would like to be having that
what is rov so
rob if if we see the concept of roi roi
have always been on the return on
investments typically in terms of the
financial values and the intangible
benefits that were not really realized
and otherwise thank you for certain and
a lot of those
outcomes which have been intangible was
not really been effectively
communicated to the business those
conversions really didn't happen to the
extent it should really be and thus roi
i feel has been
really a failure for
it to really communicate how effectively
we have
created value for the business so return
on value that it reflects both tangible
as well as intangible benefits
it drives revenue over time so
especially when we see those intangible
benefits and they are
resulting in tangible benefits over time
so that is where rv drives the renewable
time and it can be used
to value the investments from multiple
perspectives what these perspectives are
you will see in the next slide but rmb
highlights the rov along with other
intangible values or benefits that a
initiative would result in
so
you can say either way is roi plus a lot
of other outcomes which your initiative
provides to the business
so now i'd like to explain the various
perspectives of rov now
the first one being the business
perspective so
typically business perspective would
reflect value generated by factors that
impact business
customers image or customers perception
in any way
so
the value creation that happens here is
typically in terms of market share brand
value customers perception of the
business services
regulatory adherence and so on
the second perspective is the strategic
perspective so static perspective
reflects value generated by factors that
impact the strategic direction of the
organization
now
strategic direction uh the static
perspective is
significantly uh
influenced by business perspective and
thus both business and strategic
perspectives are very tightly coupled
so value creation here typically happens
in terms of the strategic advantage that
the organization can gain uh compliance
etc
the third perspective is
the service perspective so service
perspective affects value generated by
factors that impact the services so it
could be
service performance reliability
availability etc
the fourth perspective is the process
perspective process perspective reflects
value generated by factors that impact
the process so it could be
related to your process kpis which we
come across quite frequently it
could be
in terms of the value generated through
governance control
and so on
the fifth fifth perspective is the
operational perspective so reflects
value generated by factors which
are basically influencing operational
aspects so here
the outcomes would be in terms of
efficiency productivity cost of failures
and so on
the last perspective
is people so a people perspective
reflects value that is generated by
factors that influence the people
aspects of the organization so this
could be skill
knowledge culture and so on
so any itl initiative
will
create value for at least one of these
perspectives
this value can be measured and showcased
by the value factors
now
so
if you see in this slide the value
factors across these perspectives that
we have identified are competitive edge
time to market optimization compliance
and so on
now the initiative will trigger the
source of value
to generate the value for these value
services this source is what i
call as value source and the outcome
that it produces is the value
of your outcome
so
if you see the competitive edge the
value sources time to market and better
market position so due to this what
would happen
organization would have increased
revenue share
it would have a market leadership so
these are the values which
this value source has created for the
value factor
same with time to market if you see it
is more of quicker design and
development of new business services or
offerings and that is what would
lead to the creation of this value
factor so what would be the result be
the result typically is your increased
market share your organization is
recognized as four
runners organizations recognize an
innovator and so on now if you see each
of these values
host of them it is very difficult to
directly attribute to
the tangible benefit which
the outcome would lead to
if because of your
initiative you are recognized as an
innovator
down the line you might have certain ips
that you have created they
may result in financial gains
but immediate period if it's for three
years it might happen that that patent
has given you a return after five years
or
your innovator
recognition as an innovator in the
market space leading to increasing your
market share so
that is how
eventually the market transformation
would happen for you so
it is really difficult to link
the degree of gain
to
these intangible benefits at times
same way for optimization uh
again if you see here we're talking
about a new concept called as tcc so
excuse me so
again these value factors and the value
they generate along with
uh
the way we are going to measure very
critical
now
if you see tcc here is another concept
that we had introduced in our bookmaking
sam works uh i will not get it into the
detail of it right now but for generic
understanding it is a replacement of the
concept of pco total cost of ownership
in the
subscription based
service error
so
now we we would be using
this sort of
concept in our example but before we do
that we need to understand that these
value factors and the values they
generate
along
is what is going to really measure and
report the value that has been discussed
and agreed with the business so uh
all of these parameters ideally should
be aggregated with the business so that
is where you uh try to
set the perception right that on what
basis the reporting or measurement would
happen so this is a critical activity
since by doing this not only do we
listen to what the business wants but
also set the correct expectations with
them
so
when we are defining or
agreeing with the business on what we
are going to report what we are going to
measure how we are going to
report a value on all of these
value factors has to be agreed along
with the value and then the reporting
would happen based on
each of those value parameters so we
will
see more that in detail in the next
couple of slides
so again going back to our example uh
what value has this initiative period
for the business now
if you see here that it has helped in
competitive edge because with better
market position because it did your
increased
in uptime
there's an increase revenue
and this is how
your
value source of better market position
has helped you to transform that value
or realize that value
from optimization perspective since now
you have uh
performed a corrective action preventive
action which would mean uh that
your
downtime for the service has decreased
that would also mean that the your tco
or tcc has reduced because now you
maintain this cost for that has been
come now
improved serviceability of additional
uptime of 0.1 percent
is there
now from customer experience management
perspective since customers are not
having a failed transaction there
or
they are able to access
your services
properly it would lead to improved
customer satisfaction levels now this
can be calculated based on customer
service
and you need to map it to a particular
initiative so how effectively the
service designed would really be
responsible for proper articulation here
reduce customer complaints because now
uptime is there so can we directly be
calculated based on the ticket reduction
of related incidents and service calls
improved customer uh retention now this
can be calculated based on the repeat uh
transactions from the customer so if we
are seeing the increase in repeat
customer
or the rate of repeat customer has
increased after the particular
initiative has happened
then definitely to a certain degree this
increase can directly be attributed to
that particular initiative if no other
initiatives has happened in parallel
so this is how we can attribute uh
the realized value in every sense now
another important thing here we are
talking about the stake holder value so
typically
your
stakeholder shareholder value
would result only when their
return on their shares increases so
if the company is able to
convert more revenue that would mean
that better
realization or profit margin has
increased so that would mean that your
shareholder value would also increase
so who should showcase the value
that it generates
so
value that any uh initiative
generates is always realized at three
levels and
this is from where a perspective has
been derived
and derived so strategic tactical and
operational so operational is where our
internal suppliers and teams are there
so you would have
these team members providing the value
that each of them has been able to uh
convert or realize to their team leads
and in
turn these team leads would be able to
really attribute
the services which
their particular technical towers or
technical teams has provided to the
overall i.t services so the contribution
to each of those services they would be
in a position to articulate
and then at the tactical level this is
the way your delivery head comes in uh
they would be able to relate
the outcomes from these i.t services
to the business service level so that's
the strategic layer so
delivery head would accumulate the
results from all the team leads and
then create the dashboard for the cio so
cio would have the dashboard related to
all the iit services and the way it
contributes to the business services and
then cio would have to present this
overall business dashboard to
the business and this is what we call as
the
business value
dashboard so let's see what that would
mean
so we will cover that in a couple of
slides later but uh right now let's try
to really see that how we can really
adopt rov in our organizations
so
the
critical thing is that there are
challenges
so it's not really
easy that we straight away adopt any uh
new concept so what are those challenges
that are that exist in using roe so
mindset that benefit exists only in
dollar value
so this is a common mindset that
most of our people have and
this would be one of the major
challenges when we are trying to
come out with this concept
getting value realization details from
internal teams and supplier teams
because
all of those people should be trained
and be aware that how should they be
projecting their value
accumulating and projecting the relevant
value parameters to distinct business
stakeholders so how would you really
collate those and create the next level
of dashboards for the next
level
now apportioning uh the contribution of
the initiative to overall gain so
whereas especially their subjective
gains and
the game sector may relate to some other
games how are you really able to
apportionate that how are you able to
show that yes the increase in the sales
has been due to this particular
initiative and this is where your
involvement of business is really
required and definition of value driven
by perception so
typically in host of cases value
is driven by perception and that is what
we need to
take care of through our
engagement with business so how do we
really address these because it's very
important that we
are able to handle these challenges so
we need to involve some of the key
players and that would be required for
calculating the rov quantitative terms
especially when we're trying to relate
something to
the business and strategical
perspectives of
the market share brand value and so on
to calculate how do we
quantitative term convert intangible
value into tangible values how do we
really convert that it has to be
aggregated with the business
realize and highlight the gain post the
closure of id projector initiative
so
yes iit initiative has closed but its
benefit realization
for all those intangible uh
games would happen after a certain
period of time
ensure i t service systems processor
solution is aptly linked link value
realization of business services to i.t
services and work with business too
agreeing on the model that would be used
to calculate and report value so some of
your key players to make
uh ro adoption success are your cxos and
view heads sales and others and market
research teams strategic teams vrms and
your complete internal uh
or external i.t teams
now it is very important that you create
the rov mindset in the organization
across all your teams so the following
questions which
is shown in the slide is what will help
your team member and enable them to
start thinking from the rv perspective
for every activity they do to complete
their day-to-day tasks so they should
know that what businesses they're
supporting how
we are supporting that business and what
are those services that we are providing
i've seen that unfortunately at the
team level uh this insight really is not
there and
that entire gap exists from the visual
services to the id component side and
this is one of the main culprits to
really
show value the
customer so
why should business really appreciate
your services
how you
your services would add value
to the business
now how easy it is for the business to
replace your service so if it is easy
that would mean
that it is even more essential for you
to effectively communicate so you have
the replacement options in the
either in the organization or outside
the organization
what will happen if your services are
unavailable to business and how do
business measure success and this value
of
the services they consume and this is
what we relate to the listen part that
we discussed earlier
so we need to remember the key
and
these are that we identify
that business what business care is
about
work with business and agree on the
method and model to calculate and report
value align annual metrics enable
measurement through tools and evolve
continuously so we should not do a big
bang
approach for this have some a
decent roadmap created which can be
achievable and start reporting
accordingly
so
it is extremely critical for us to
showcase the value of the next layer and
gial's law of reporting says that as the
length of the report increases the odds
of anyone reading it decreases so our
rov report has to be short and sweet
this is where the business value
dashboards become a critical tool a
simple tool that i have used multiple
times is what we are covering in this uh
as well as the next slide and again this
is based on the bookmaking science
you may use
this or any other similar representation
or any other representation which is
deep fit in your organization
but we need to produce such dashboard
covering all elements of the value
factors that we have agreed with the
business and
for all layers of your teams
so
this is how you can uh so just just take
a couple of
those
value factors and the value which has
been generated and showing the status
for that so this goes to the business
and at the next layer we have the rv
report which now goes to is given by
uh say a problem management
team
the software asset management team they
have given their
value they have been able to generate so
for example here in this case we have
considered that there was a license
breach because of which
penalty was imposed
so
customers incurred a cost
there so i have not really created a
value but drain out the value
so you can use any of these
reports and finally for any questions
that you may have
i hope okay
something thank you for this part of the
presentation it was really exciting and
great and now let me to open pulling
activity and during the pulling activity
i will ask our attendees to provide and
share their opinions and provide their
response on that and during this time
quickly i would like to open a few
questions we had as i chose from from
our attendees and probably you should go
and quickly provide the response to that
are you agree with me on that summit
yeah
sure okay okay let me to open polling
activity and guys please
provide us your response are you looking
for a training provider for your team
and
in the meantime i would like to open uh
one question from
dvarakanath
can we have some example of converting
in tangible to to tangible value
could you provide us some quick examples
of it even that we are running a little
bit over the time
okay
okay so you already covered but uh just
quickly
yeah so like the example that we covered
here was uh 0.1 percent uptime so how
does it really translate into business
value for so when we see that as say
a gain of 5k is there per
hour or so we convert the uptime gain
into that particular time period
multiplied by the opportunity cost and
that gives me my
tangible uh gain so i've been able to
convert one of the intangible values
into tangible values now it becomes
difficult when you try to relate into
the business side of things and that is
where we need involvement of the
business because uh
relating an initiative to increase in
market share because
for example if this was a banking
uh transaction and your transaction has
increased so your sales on your portal
has happened
so okay
uh another question please from kumar
and he asked actually and said please
share an email with tcc and tco
definitional calculation
unit of measurement could you
quickly let's say provide some response
on tcc and tc or even that you cover
this part
yeah so tcu like you understand is
basically for all the assets that the
organization holds like so right from
the time when you bought the particular
asset to the time when uh you eventually
need support for that uh so all of those
costs for the entire lifecycle of the
asset is what is attributed as tcpo now
uh when in a subscription world when
you're consuming the services
this concept does not really work
so it's based now on the cost of
consumption because based on a certain
migration initiative that you've done to
move to a subscription model you may
have some other costs attached to it uh
which may be a migration cost or
sustainable costs or maintenance costs
and so on so you need to
convert all of those and for the life
cycle of
your subscription
of the service and then arrive at the
tcc
so
those are covered in detail in the book
okay i would like to ask you our
attendees just to finish this polling
activity and
let's see very last question even that
we have another and another question
summit
obviously that everything is pretty
interesting for our attendees and the
question from g1 is
would you have a matrix sample of a
value delivered to business matter fixed
goals achievements
correlating to i.t metrics
i couldn't would you have matrix sample
of value delivered to a business metrics
goal achievement correlated to writing
matrix yes so this is where the
even if you see
this particular slide
here so here now this is completely for
the business
dashboard now if i go to the next layer
see if your team is driving proactive
problem management and you are one of
those problem managers you would create
some
one report like this which has to be
then accumulated and quality together by
the next level so we are able to relate
those so when you convert those
gains
which you have been able to realize
typically problem management will lead
to incident reduction uh uptime and so
on so because any integration would mean
again enough time
so so that is where you need to work
with the business to understand that
what is opportunity cost for them for
the services that are impacted now
because of what you have done it may be
possible that 10 different services
has
gained in terms of the performance
gains in terms of additional
transactions so you need to really
convert those
understand what the opportunity cost for
each of those services are and then
attribute that to the gain enough time
okay summit i think that
we covered the question as we had and as
i said now we are a little bit over the
time and
thank you for the great presentation and
uh thank you to our attendees that they
came today on this great webinar stay
with us and uh
happy simple learning thank you summit
and goodbye to all of you guys
you